♪
>> WELCOME TO THE SPECIAL
EDITION OF HANNITY THE TRUMP
AGENDA, PRESIDENT TRUMP HE
ROCKED THE CROWD, HE
DELIVERED A ROUSING SPEECH
AT CPAC 2018 TONIGHT FOR THE
HOUR WE HAVE THE HIGHLIGHTS
AND, OF COURSE, REACTION ALL
OF THIS WE WILL CHECK IN
WITH JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
WE START WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S PLAN TO PROTECT
AMERICAN SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS FOLLOWING THIS
TRAGEDY IN FLORIDA.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S TIME TO MAKE OUR
SCHOOLS A MUCH HARDER TARGET
FOR ATTACKERS.
WE DON'T WANT THEM IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
[APPLAUSE]
WE DON'T WANT THEM.
WHEN WE DECLARE OUR SCHOOLS
TO BE GUN-FREE ZONES IT JUST
PUTS OUR STUDENTS IN FAR
MORE DANGER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
FAR MORE DANGER.
[APPLAUSE]
WELL-TRAINED, GUN ADEPT
TEACHERS AND COACHES AND
PEOPLE THAT WORK THIS THOSE
BUILDINGS.
PEOPLE IN THE MARINES FOR 20
YEARS AND RETIRED.
PEOPLE IN THE ARMY, THE
NAVY, THE AIR FORCE, THE
COAST GUARD.
PEOPLE THAT ARE ADEPT, ADEPT
WITH WEAPONRY AND WITH GUNS.
THEY TEACH.
I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
100 GUARDS STANDING WITH
RIFLES ALL OVER THE SCHOOL.
YOU DO A CONCEAL CARRY
PERMIT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND THIS WOULD BE A MAJOR
DETERRENT BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE ARE INHERENTLY
COWARDICE.
IF THEY THOUGHT LIKE IF THIS
GUY THOUGHT THAT OTHER
PEOPLE WOULD BE SHOOTING
BULLETS BACK AT HIM, HE
WOULDN'T HAVE GONE TO THAT
SCHOOL.
HE WOULDN'T HAVE GONE THERE.
IT'S A GUN-FREE ZONE.
IT SAYS THIS IS A GUN-FREE
ZONE.
PLEASE CHECK WHERE
PLEASE CHECK YHERE
PLEASE CHECK YOURE
PLEASE CHECK YOUR GUNS WAY
FAR AWAY.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY FEEL
SAFE.
NOBODY IS GOING TO COME AT
THEM.
THIS WAY YOU MAY HAVE --
AND, REMEMBER, IF YOU USE
THIS SCHOOL AS AN EXAMPLE,
THIS IS A VERY BIG SCHOOL.
WITH TREMENDOUS FLOOR AREA
AND A LOT OF ACREAGE.
IT'S A BIG, BIG SCHOOL.
GOOD SCHOOL.
A BIG, BIG SCHOOL.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE 150
REAL GUARDS.
LOOK, YOU HAD ONE GUARD, HE
DIDN'T TURN OUT TO BE TOO
GOOD.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT HE
TURNED OUT TO BE NOT GOOD.
HE WAS NOT A CREDIT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THAT I CAN TELL
YOU.
THAT, I CAN TELL YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
AS I HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS IDEA AND I FEEL IT'S A
GREAT IDEA BUT SOME PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOOD PEOPLE ARE
OPPOSED TO IT.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
TEACHERS DOING THAT I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT TEACHERS.
YOU KNOW, CNN WENT ON AND
THEY SAID DONALD TRUMP WANTS
ALL TEACHERS, OKAY.
>> FAKE NEWS, FOLKS, FAKE
NEWS.
FAKE NEWS.
I DON'T WANT A PERSON THAT'S
NEVER HANDLED A GUN THAT
WOULDN'T KNOW WHAT A GUN
LOOKS LIKE TO BE ARMED.
BUT OUT OF YOUR TEACHING
POPULATION, OUT OF YOUR
TEACHING POPULATION YOU HAVE
10%, 20%, A VERY GUN ADEPT
PEOPLE.
MILITARY PEOPLE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE.
THEY TEACH.
AND SOMETHING I THOUGHT OF
THIS MORNING, YOU KNOW WHAT
ELSE?
AND I THOUGHT OF IT SINCE I
FOUND AND WATCHED PETERSON.
THE DEPUTY WHO DIDN'T GO
INTO THE SCHOOL BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T WANT TO GO INTO THE
SCHOOL.
OKAY?
HE WAS TESTED UNDER FIRE AND
THAT WASN'T A GOOD RESULT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THOUGHT OF
AS SOON AS I SAW THAT?
THESE TEACHERS AND I HAVE
SEEN THEM, AND A LOT OF
SCHOOLS WHERE THEY HAD
PROBLEMS THESE TEACHERS
LOVED THEIR STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS LOVED THEIR
TEACHERS.
THESE TEACHERS LOVED THEIR
STUDENTS.
THESE TEACHERS ARE TALENTED
WITH WEAPONRY AND WITH GUNS.
AND THAT'S -- THEY FEEL
SAFE.
AND I WOULD RATHER HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT LOAVES THEIR
STUDENTS AND WANTS TO
PROTECT THEIR STUDENTS THAN
SOMEBODY STANDING OUTSIDE
THAT DOESN'T KNOW ANYBODY
AND DOESN'T KNOW THE
STUDENTS AND, FRANKLY, FOR
WHATEVER REASON, DECIDED NOT
TO GO IN, EVEN THOUGH HE
HEARD LOTS OF SHOTS BEING
FIRED INSIDE THE TEACHERS
AND COACHES AND OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE BUILDING, THE DEAN,
THE ASSISTANT DEAN, THE
PRINTS PELL THEY CAN -- THEY
LOVE THEIR PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO PROTECT THESE
KIDS I THINK WE ARE BETTER
WITH THAT.
AND THIS MAY BE 10% OR 20%
OF THE POPULATION OF
TEACHERS, ET CETERA.
IT'S NOT ALL OF THEM BUT YOU
WOULD HAVE A LOT.
YOU WOULD TELL PEOPLE THAT
THEY ARE INSIDE.
THE BEAUTY IS IT'S
CONCEALED.
NOBODY WOULD EVER SEE IT.
UNLESS THEY NEEDED IT IT'S
CONCEALED.
SO THIS CRAZY MAN WHO WALKED
IN WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW WHO IT
IS THAT HAS IT.
THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
AND THE TEACHER WOULD HAVE
SHOT THE HELL OUT OF HIM
BEFORE HE KNEW WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Sean: PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
TRYING TO BLAME THE NRA FOR
THE SHOOTING IN FLORIDA
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP
DEFENDED OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS TO KEEP AND TO BEAR
ARMS.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> DON'T BE COMPLACENT.
DON'T BE COMPLACENT.
BECAUSE, IF THEY GET IN,
THEY WILL REPEAL YOUR TAX
CUTS.
THEY WILL PUT JUDGES IN THAT
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
THEY WILL TAKE AWAY YOUR
WILL NEVER ALLOW TO HAPPEN.
SECOND ASSESSMENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
U REMEMBER THAT THEY WILL
TAKE AWAY -- THANK YOU.
THEY WILL TAKE AWAY THOSE
MASSIVE TAX CUTS AND THEY
WILL TAKE AWAY YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT.
BY THE WAY IF YOU ONLY HAD A
CHOICE OF ONE WHAT WOULD YOU
RATHER HAVE SECOND AMENDMENT
OR TAX CUTS?
GO AHEAD SEX AMENDMENT, TAX
CUTS.
SECOND AMENDMENT.
[CHEERS]
>> I'M GOING TO LEAVE IT AT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
THAT BATTLE.
ALL RIGHT?
HE WOULD ARE GOING TO SAY
YOU WANT -- WE ARE GOING TO
SAY YOU WANT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT THE MOST.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO GET THEM
ALL.
THERE IS NOBODY THAT LOVES
THE SECOND AMENDMENT MORE
THAN I DO.
AND THERE IS NOBODY THAT
RESPECTS THE NRA, THEY ARE
FRIENDS OF MINE.
THEY BACKED US ALL.
THEY ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PATRIOTS.
BUT THEY ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
BUT WE REALLY DO HAVE TO
STRENGTHEN UP, REALLY
STRENGTHEN UP BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE HAVE TO DO FOR THE
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE THAT
ARE MENTALLY ILL TO BE
HAVING ANY FORM OF WEAPONRY.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY STRONG ON
THAT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THAT
CONGRESS IS GOING TO GET IT
THROUGH THIS TIME.
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
LEADER.
THEY HAVE SOMEBODY WHO WANTS
TO GET IT THROUGH.
NOT JUST SOMEBODY WHO IS ALL
TALK NO ACTION LIKE SO MANY
OF THESE FOLKS, THIS IS
SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO GET IT
THROUGH.
WE ALSO NEED TO CREATE A
CULTURE IN OUR COUNTRY THAT
CHERISHES LIFE AND HUMAN
DIGNITY.
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
A CULTURE THAT CONDEMNS
VIOLENCE AND NEVER GLORIFIES
VIOLENCE.
WE NEED TO FORCE THE REAL
HUMAN CONNECTIONS AND TURN
CLASSMATES AND COLLEAGUES
INTO FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
THAT WANT TO FIGHT FOR US.
WE'RE NOT JUST HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SCHOOL
SAFETY.
YOU'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS IN
ALL FAIRNESS, I'M PRETTY NEW
IN THIS JOB.
MORE THAN A YEAR.
I HAVE BEEN WATCHING THIS
STUFF GO ON FOR 20 YEARS.
THE PRESIDENT GETS UP,
EVERYBODY IS ENTHUSIASTIC
DAYS.
THEN IT FADES, FADES, FADES,
NOTHING EVER GETS DONE.
WE WANT TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
IT DONE.
LET'S GET IT DONE RIGHT.
WE REALLY OWE IT TO OUR
COUNTRY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ISTIC WATCHING FOR A LONG
TIME SEEN A LOT OF WORDS AND
SEEN VERY LITTLE ACTION.
AND YOU KNOW, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT MOST OF IT IS JUST
COMMON SENSE.
IT'S NOT DO YOU LOVE GUNS?
DO YOU HATE GUNS?
IT'S COMMON SENSE.
IT'S ALL COMMON SENSE.
AND SOME OF THE STRONGEST
ADVOCATES ABOUT WHAT I'M
ADVOCATES I KNOW THEM VERY
WELL.
POLITICAL PEOPLE, THE
STRONGEST ADVOCATES FOR THE
SECOND AMENDMENT THIS IS
COMMON SENSE.
IN ADDITION TO SECURING OUR
SCHOOLS, WE ARE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING A STRATEGY TO
SECURE OUR STREETS.
WE WANT OUR KIDS TO BE SAFE
EVERYWHERE THEY GO WHETHER
THEY ARE IN A CLASSROOM,
WALKING HOME FROM SCHOOL OR
JUST OUTSIDE PLAYING WITH
THEIR FRIENDS.
EVERY CHILD DESERVES TO GROW
UP IN A SAFE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDED BY A LOVING
FAMILY AND TO HAVE A FUTURE
FILLED WITH OPPORTUNITY AND
WITH HOPE.
>> ALSO TODAY THE PRESIDENT
IS MAKING MAJOR SWEEPING
SANCTION AGAINST THE ROGUE
REGIME.
NORTH CAROLINA.
NOW
NORTH KOREA.
SANCTIONS LARGEST EVER
AGAINST PYONGYANG, MEANT TO
CUT OFF MONEY AND SUPPLIES
TO THE DICTATOR KIM JONG
U.N. AND USING THAT MONEY TO
ADVANCE HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCING THOSE NEWS
SANCTIONS EARLIER.
>> I DO WANT TO SAY BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE ASKED NORTH
KOREA, WE IMPOSE TODAY THE
HEAVIEST SANCTIONS EVER
IMPOSED ON A COUNTRY BEFORE.
AND FRANKLY HOPEFULLY
SOMETHING POSITIVE CAN
HAPPEN.
WE WILL SEE.
BUT HOPEFULLY SOMETHING
POSITIVE CAN HAPPEN.
BUT THAT JUST WAS ANNOUNCED
AND I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE IMPOSED THE HEAVIEST
SANCTIONS EVER IMPOSED.
>> Sean: ALSO THE PRESIDENT
TODAY LISTED HIS MANY
ACCOMPLISH US AND THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT THE LIBERAL
MAINSTREAM DESTROY TRUMP
MEDIA COVERS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT?
IT DOESN'T FIT THEIR
NARRATIVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FROM THE LAST YEAR WITH
YOUR HELP, WE HAVE PUT MORE
GREAT CONSERVATIVE IDEAS
INTO USE THAN PERHAPS EVER
BEFORE IN PERSONAL HISTORY
WE HAVE CONFIRMED A RECORD
NUMBER SO IMPORTANT OF
CIRCUIT JUDGES AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE PUTTING IN A LOT
MORE.
AND THEY WILL INTERPRET THE
LAW AS WRITTEN.
WE WILL CONFIRM A INCREDIBLE
NEW SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
A GREAT MAN NEIL GORSUCH.
RIGHT?
WE HAVE PASSED MASSIVE,
BIGGEST IN HISTORY TAX CUTS
AND REFORMS.
IT'S CALLED THE TAX CUT ACT
AND JOBS.
WE HAD TO ADD JOBS IN TO IT
BECAUSE WE ARE PICKING UP
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF JOBS.
2.7 MILLION JOBS.
2.7.
REMEMBER THIS NOT ONLY DID
WE GET THE TAX CUTS, WHICH
EVERYBODY SAID WE WOULDN'T
GET AND BY THE WAY REPEALED
IN TAX CUT THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE.
WHICH IS A TREMENDOUS THING.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THIS IS WHERE YOU ARE FORCED
TO PAY IN ORDER NOT TO HAVE
HEALTHCARE.
OKAY?
IS THAT GREAT?
YOU PAY NOR THE PRIVILEGE OF
NOT HAVING HEALTHCARE.
SO YOU SUBSIDIZING LOTS OF
OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT'S GONE.
I KNOW PEOPLE CAME UP WITH
ME WITH TEARS IN THEIR EYES
I'M FORCED TO PAY NOT TO
HAVE HEALTHCARE.
VERY UNFAIR.
BY THE WAY WE ARE HAVING
TREMENDOUS HEALTHCARE PLANS
COMING OUT AT A FRACTION OF
THE COST THAT ARE MUCH
BETTER THAN OBAMACARE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND EXCEPT FOR ONE SENATOR,
WHO CAME ON TO A ROOM AT
3:00 IN THE MORNING AND WENT
LIKE THAT, WE WOULD HAVE HAD
HEALTHCARE, TOO.
[CROWD BOOS]
WE WOULD HAVE HAD
HEALTHCARE, TOO.
THINK OF THAT BUT I THINK WE
MAY BE BETTER OFF THE WAY WE
ARE DOING IT PIECE BY PIECE
BY PIECE OBAMACARE IS JUST
BEING WIPED OUT.
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
ESSENTIALLY WIND IT OUT.
HEALTHCARE PLANS NOT
FINISHED YET.
REMEMBER, ONE PERSON WALKED
INTO A ROOM WHEN HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO THIS WAY.
AND HE SAID HE WAS GOING
THIS WAY AND HE WALKED IN
AND HE WENT THIS WAY AND
EVERYONE SAID WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT WAS THAT ALL ABOUT I
DON'T KNOW.
YOU I DON'T WANT TO BE
CONTROVERSIAL SO I WON'T USE
HIS NAME.
OKAY?
WHAT A MESS.
BUT, IT'S ALL HAPPENING
ANYWAY.
IT'S ALL HAPPENING ANYWAY.
AND WE HAVE AT THE SAME TIME
ELIMINATED A RECORD NUMBER
OF JOB KILLING REGULATIONS
AND PEOPLE ARE GOING BACK TO
WORK.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER CUT SO
MANY REGULATIONS IN THEIR
ENTIRE TERM.
AS WE HAVE CUT IN LESS THAN
A YEAR.
WE HAVE ENDED THE WAR ON
AMERICAN ENERGY WE WERE IN
WAR AND WE ENDED THE WAR ON
BEAUTIFUL CLEAN COAL.
REMEMBER THIS VIRTUALLY AS
SOON AS I GOT INTO OFFICE,
WE APPROVED THE KEYSTONE
EXCEL PIPELINE AND THE
DAKOTA ACCESS PIPELINES
WHICH WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
APPROVED.
WE KNOCKED OUT THE PARIS
CLIMATE ACCORD.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A DISASTER.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
DISASTER FOR OUR COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH OUR COUNTRY,
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
THE FUNDAMENTALS ARE SO
STRONG.
THE STOCK MARKET I SEE WITH
ALL OF THE UPS AND DOWNS
SINCE ELECTION DAY.
IS UP 37%.
37%.
IT WAS UP 100, UP 200, UP
1,000, UP 150, UP 90.
UP 63.
I SAID GOODNESS, THAT'S
BETTER.
HEY.
WE GOT SEVEN YEARS TO GO U
JUST IN FINISHING, OUR
COUNTRY IS DOING VERY WELL.
OUR ECONOMY IS BLAZING.
JOBS ARE AT A RECORD LEVEL.
JOBS ARE SO GOOD.
2.7 MILLION JOBS CREATED
SINCE THE ELECTION.
>> WE'RE WINNING.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS HAVE
REACHED A 45-YEAR LOW
AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT HAS REACHED THE
LOWEST LEVEL IN OUR HISTORY.
HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT HAS
REACHED THE LOWEST LEVEL IN
OUR HISTORY.
WOMEN, WOMEN UNEMPLOYMENT IS
AT THE LOWEST LEVEL IN 18
YEARS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WAGES ARE RISING FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MANY, MANY
YEARS.
[APPLAUSE]
SMALL BUSINESS CONFIDENCE IS
AT A RECORD HIGH AND THANKS
TO OUR MASSIVE TAX CUTS,
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
GETTING TO KEEP A GREAT
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR MONEY
INSTEAD OF PAYING IT TO A
GOVERNMENT THAT THROWS IT
OUT THE WINDOW.
SO I JUST LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS:  WE HAVE TO FIGHT
NANCY PELOSI.
THEY WANT TO GIVE YOUR MONEY
AWAY.
THEY WANT TO END YOUR TAX
CUTS.
THEY WANT TO DO THINGS THAT
YOU WOULDN'T EVEN BELIEVE.
INCLUDING TAKING YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS AWAY.
THEY WILL DO THAT.
[CROWD BOOING.
BOOING]
WE HAVE TO FIGHT IN '18 LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
JUST THE WAY YOU FOUGHT WITH
US.
YOU FOUGHT SO HARD AND YOU
WERE SO TOUGH AND YOU WERE